we need to find out how nucci got the
debbie fortunately it turns out she kept
a fairly comprehensive diary as a power
journaler i think we can hold off on
using the word comprehensive oh damn
that's comprehensive
these are all just from this year this
one is labeled august 21st
morning this one is august 21st evening
this entire diary is about an episode of
house hunters this is gonna take forever
i actually took a speed reading course i
tested at 800 wpm
that's pathetic i tested at 802. that's
pretty close to hold score no no 802's
incredible she poned me
i read the entire urban dictionary so i
could converse with the other uniformed
officers
finished it in 47 minutes i've never
been so attracted to a gay man before
and i dated several in college so we
have a read-off santiago we don't have
finger guards so we do it raw
okay i normally don't encourage such
childish competitions but this might
help things go faster my only question
is
ho are you sure your old ass eyes are up
to the challenge i know you're just
trying to motivate me but these old ass
eyes will be reading your tombstone
son
[Music]
so how's it going what do you want terry
are you just here to fan some more
flames
no i'm just here to see who's losing and
therefore has to wear this hat i made
that says more stupider fine yeah i'm
fanning flames fan fan fan fan fan
santiago don't call her santiago call
her virginia slim
because i'm smoking her damn ray
you guys are moving fast but there's no
way you're actually comprehending
anything i'm taking my time and reading
deliberately and you know what they say
slow and steady wins the race classic
reg reader bullcrap
yeah what are you gonna say next that
you read to relax
[Laughter]
this is ridiculous neither of you have
even taken a bathroom break
are you kidding me do you think world
record holder howard berg would stop in
the middle of a read-off
to expel what's going on inside the
other
it's nothing it's my guide finger got
paper burn
let me see santiago you're hurt
don't be a hero
damn you must have been cooking i was
let's take a break put some ointment on
that
right and when i come back my finger's
slipping all over the page
nice try i'm not falling for any of your
tricks oh but you already have
while you were waggling your finger in
the air i've been reading all this time
out of the corner of my eye
damn it i just talked to the manager at
the hotel where the handoff was
happening he said debbie's room was
empty and there's no sign of rosa or
jake is there anything in those diaries
that can help us find him debbie
mentions her mom a bunch and one of the
ones i read
seems like she tells her everything oh
that's a good lead it is a good lead
isn't it did you hear that speed freaks
let's find out all we can about the mob
i'll start reading right away because
slow and steady wins
her mother's name is margaret jean foley
she lives in benson she drives a maroon
lexus vanity plates
derrick's mom she's married three times
to horace mills then frank yeltsin and
then james falls she goes grocery
shopping on tuesday order aerobics on
wednesdays book club on friday she
drinks too much wine always a pinot
grigio always from nampa
the race slow and steady wins the race
you